some see it as the ultimate selfless act
ever was potentially losing her life on
the table
but surrogacy carrying a child for
someone else is also a fast-growing
global trade one that's transforming
ideas about family the legal definition
of family is changing over time what's
driving this boom in the baby business
I've done I believe over 8 000 surrogate
Cycles in my career outlawed and hated
in many countries the inside of a
woman's body is being used as a
workplace how can surrogacy be better
the least
and its children better protected
[Music]
good morning Hi how are you
feeling excited a little bit nervous
Jessica has signed up to provide the
gift of life
this is just giving us permission to
place the embryo into your uterus just
print sign and date right there
Jessica is a surrogate
and she has no genetic link to the
embryo which is about to be implanted
into her
I love being able to help someone to be
able to have a family that they're not
able to on their own
gestational surrogacy as it's known is
now significantly more common than
surrogates using their own eggs
Jessica's Doctor David smartridge is one
of its leading practitioners
for those of us who do a lot of
surrogacy find that gestational
surrogacy is a better approach and it
makes it much easier in terms of
everybody involved
the genetic makeup of the child is
something that is very very concerning
for the overwhelming majority of couples
that we work with
Jessica has had to pass stringent
medical and psychological vetting
procedures
who is driving you home today my husband
will be picking me up okay
and most Californian agencies require
surrogates to be mothers already
for my kids I've always sold a mom's
babysitting so they have always known
that the baby that I'm carrying is not
ours
I'm gonna take you back and just get
started okay
all the testing that we're doing on her
and her body actually is for another
couple
all righty it's nice that they're awake
[Music]
that couple on Nema and Hamish
based in Australia they are the intended
parents as they're often called
in Australia it's very difficult to
adopt surrogacy sort of felt like really
the only reliable option in terms of
having a child
the embryo implanted inside Jessica was
made using nema's sperm and an egg from
an American donor
hello
Jessica has already given the couple a
son Hugo
now they're hoping she'll add a baby
girl to the family
Jessica are you ready I'm ready okay
you're gonna feel my fingertips first
and then speculum okay here we go
California so often at the Forefront of
new technologies has become the
surrogacy capital of the world
I've done I believe over 8 000 surrogate
Cycles in my career we've helped couples
in over a hundred different countries
become families
if you look at the screen behind me
we're going to show you the actual
embryo that we are going to transfer
back in 1998 David was one of the first
doctors to help same-sex couples become
parents through surrogacy
[Music]
this is my trial catheter
and covering you up
some may say you can't put a price on
having a family but here in California
they do
intended parents usually pay between a
hundred and ten thousand dollars to
upwards of two hundred thousand dollars
for surrogacy services
and surrogates like Jessica can earn
between thirty thousand and sixty
thousand dollars do you want to stop and
make your appointment for Monday yeah
when you're a first time surrogate you
obviously don't know if ibf is going to
work for you so as you go into a second
one the pay increases because obviously
they know that you can carry this baby
with no issues
thing about everything that we are
putting our body through to be able to
have this baby
the Nema the transactional nature of the
relationship with Jessica is part of the
appeal
I see it as a win-win she is doing
something amazing for us able to earn
some money through it to help her own
family and has made the decision herself
the number of children born to surrogacy
globally is unknown
data only exists for some countries such
as Britain
and this shows a small but increasing
number of Parental orders
transfers of custodial rights from
surrogates to intended parents
but globally the surrogacy industry was
estimated to be worth over 14 billion
dollars in 2022 a figure that may rise
as high as 130 billion dollars over the
coming decade
same-sex couples wanting children are
one of the key drivers of this growth
in Britain for example about half of all
intended parents are gay
the legal definition of family is
changing over time which means that the
definition of family is now
accepted as being more than just the you
know mum dad and 2.5 children
but there's another perhaps more
significant factor making the surrogacy
business grow
declining fertility rates amongst the
heterosexual population
women are now choosing to start families
later in life and this carries a higher
risk of infertility the World Health
Organization recently produced a report
that said up to 17.5 percent of people
will be affected by infertility in their
life so that's one in six people so if
you are infertile if you have a burning
desire to have a family you generally
have tried everything else you've tried
IVF your last resort is surrogacy
surrogacy industry has also benefited
from celebrity Limelight
as the Paris Hiltons of this world keep
up with the likes of Khloe Kardashian
I went to the hospital I really think
that was the first time that really
registered you're like okay we're having
a baby
even if such famous parents are usually
living in a different Financial reality
for most
well it might be inspiring and good news
it's certainly not the norm for most
people going through these processes who
haven't got the money or the status
[Music]
what's especially striking about the
surrogacy business is how globalized
it's become
here's why
relatively few countries allow
surrogates to be expressly paid for the
labor of carrying a child
for example Georgia Ukraine and certain
states in America
however this kind of commercial
surrogacy is against the law in many
more countries
like China Germany turkey France and
Italy
that means residents of these countries
wanting a surrogate have to look abroad
the countries where surrogacy is allowed
the transnational business of surrogacy
is very fluid originally India was a
popular destination the Indian
government then didn't know we're not
going to allow foreigners to come in and
use our population for surrogacy and it
was shut down in Thailand and then it
went to Laos we're seeing an increasing
trend for countries in Europe
particularly to turn their laws against
surrogacy and to forbid their citizens
from engaging in it
opposition to surrogacy often comes from
the religious right and conservative
politicians in Italy one politician has
even compared surrogacy to child abuse
on the other side of the political
Spectrum radical feminists are often
equally opposed if the different reasons
the financial trade therefore there's
huge amounts of exploitation because the
inside of a woman's body is being used
as a workplace
it's not just hostility and laws which
push intended parents to seek surrogates
overseas it's hard economics too
for those unable to afford services in
America other countries offer lower cost
alternatives
in Greece prices start at around 88 000
while in Georgia it's less than half
that
[Music]
although in 2024 foreigners will be
banned from surrogacy Services there
before the Russian invasion Ukraine was
a Global surrogacy Hub offering
affordable prices to customers from rich
countries
you're trying almost by accident had
laws that allowed foreigners to be
enabled on the bus certificate there was
a large number of high quality IVF
clicks popped up it also has a very
large population so there was no
shortage of surrogates to meet that
demand
they are babies from America Italy Spain
Britain China France Germany as well as
from Bulgaria before the war Ukrainian
surrogates were producing over 2 500
babies each year mostly for foreigners
with half of that demand coming from
China where surrogacy is banned
foreign
the war has since reduced demand
although it's also forced aspiring
parents to take unusual measures
people will go to extreme lengths to be
United with their child wealthy
returning parents were engaging security
teams with armored vehicles to take them
into Ukraine into Kiev to pick up their
baby and take them out
the rise in IVF cheap air travel and
online marketing have all allowed
low-cost surrogacy agencies to expand
across the world
there is a dark underbelly to this
industry
in countries as widespread as Guatemala
Laos and Kenya surrogacy is neither
banned nor permitted under law
in these places the industry is
unregulated and raising concerns
this industry is really growing on its
sniper noi Le papa is a journalist in
Nairobi who exposes the human cost of
failing to regulate surrogacy
surrogates are not protected and some
are exploited
who have been intimidated
who have been forced to have abortions
and then they are defrauded out of their
money
in a country where 27 of the population
lives below the poverty line of just
over two dollars a day agencies prey on
vulnerable and illiterate women in slums
like this one in dandora
nipinoy discovered one victim who
miscarried at five months but was left
with the dead fetus inside her for days
and left crippled for life
instead of immediately removing the
fetus the agent told her he's going to
look for someone who is going to operate
on her so it took a whole week
she's always in pain she can't do
anything she's still struggling
to add insult to injury this surrogate
was never even paid you only get paid
when you produce a baby but when you you
miscarriage you're not paid anything
thank you
napanoi is on her way to meet another
victim
today I'm meeting a woman who says she
was asked for sex in exchange for work
as a surrogate
this woman agreed to be filmed provided
her identity as protected
some surrogates have said that they have
been asked for sex do
they did also happen to you
yes it happened to me yes
and I came to realize that that man is
sleeping with almost every girl
since I had no option I did it because
he was promising me he is going to shape
my life
she was recruited as a surrogate through
Facebook
and was promised a life-changing four
thousand five hundred dollars roughly
two years earnings but she was given no
medical advice
they didn't ask me to sign anything
before Embryo transfer so it was not
concerned about all those things all I
was praying for is that the process got
through well they get pregnant so they
can get the money
it is considered good practice to
transfer only one embryo to reduce the
risks to both mother and baby
this woman endured the transfer of four
embryos without choice
three of the embryos implanted
successfully and rather than risk
triplets the agency chose to abort one
she was later forced to have a Caesarean
section to deliver Twins and is still
owed over half her money
they operated on me I felt like running
away I've never experienced that kind of
pain I couldn't move I couldn't do
anything why do you think CSR performed
on surrogates
they don't care about surrogates they
just want to remove their babies
[Music]
life is much riskier for surrogate in
poor countries like Kenya where for
every 100
000 births an estimated 530 women die
by comparison in the EU that figure is
just six
[Music]
The surrogacy Market within poor
countries is often driven by Foreign
demand
so what if anything can be done to
address this Global problem of
exploitation of surrogates banning
surrogacy is not the answer just as
human rights law says you cannot tell a
woman that she has to have an abortion
or that she can't have an abortion the
same principles apply to surrogacy it is
the individual woman's Choice whether
and how she uses her reproductive system
perhaps a better idea would be to make
surrogacy legal and well regulated in
more places the fact that surrogacy is
such a transnational basis is very
problematic it will be much better if
countries could come to terms of the
fact that their Nationals do require
surrogacy and they could put the laws in
place in their own countries to allow
much easier access to surrogacy at home
in Britain one survey found that
two-thirds of intended parents chose to
go overseas for surrogacy because they
felt laws were unfavorable to them at
home
after birth it can take half a year or
more for intended parents to become
legal guardians of their surrogate
children
[Music]
how many shirts are you bringing
three
campaigners like Alan white and his
partner Nick have contributed to law
reforms that will make this process
quicker
Alan is chair of the board of surrogacy
UK a non-profit advocacy and support
group
[Music]
the law of changes will make things more
secure for all parties involved in
surrogacy surrogates under the current
law they are the legal parents of a
child born through surrogacy so actually
they carry a tremendous amount of risk
in the process oh it's not with you it
is a bit Bonkers in comparison to other
people's experience that you know you
wouldn't expect someone to turn up when
your child's six months old and decide
whether you can keep him or not
hey messy
the couple are about to take their
surrogate-born child Jago on holiday for
the first time let's go let's go let's
go but even though he is five months old
Jago is still legally not their child
don't eat your food
I think you look nice foreign
until a parental order is granted by the
courts in legal terms jago's surrogate
Emma will be left holding the baby
so you need to sit in between your legs
and need to put some toys in front of
him I knew I was legally his parent and
I knew that my husband he would have to
go on the birth certificate which is
completely not right either
in Britain surrogates like Emma cannot
be paid but can receive
pregnancy-related expenses
it's sometimes known as the altruistic
model and in Emma's case it may be hard
to find a worthier example of that term
I ended up delivering Jago and then
immediately after
um bled quite a lot so I had to be
rushed to theater
after the birth Emma had a big
postpartum Hemorrhage the room suddenly
filled with 20 medical staff crash
trolleys all the stuff that you don't
want to see Emma was potentially losing
their life on the table
the Midwifery team started talking to
him about having to do things to save
her life and it was it was horrible
Emma's six children and her husband
nearly lost her
also that Alan and Nick could become
parents
[Music]
there's no way you can thank someone for
that you just can't they just aren't the
words holding him for the first time and
realizing that this is your child that
you're responsible for his happiness and
it's amazing
yes it is
I never saw it as a massive deal to be
honest
to somebody else who couldn't have
children I've got all the bits to help
so why wouldn't I help
as well as Britain other countries using
the altruistic model include Canada and
Australia
supporters say forbidding surrogates the
charge direct fees for child wearing
reduces the risks of exploitation
however
critics point out the altruistic model
is far from a catch-all solution to
Global surrogacy's problems
when we look at who's involved in
surrogacy there's generally lawyers
the only person who's not being paid for
their services is the surrogate who's
doing let's face it most of the labor
pun intended
I would like to see minimum and maximum
amounts of compensation for surrogacy
psychological evaluations of all the
parties before they embark on surrogacy
there should be mandatory requirements
for legal advice
regulating such a global business is an
enormous Challenge
[Music]
and in the often heated debate about
this the outcomes of surrogate children
can sometimes get forgotten there is an
argument that children born by surrogacy
are somehow disadvantaged the research
doesn't support that we know that
children borne via surrogacy do as well
as the children born in other ways
a recent study suggests that telling
surrogate-born children about their
Origins early in life can help
seven percent of mothers who did this
before their child turned seven reported
problems in family relationships
compared with 22 percent who disclosed
after the age of seven
[Music]
your views
at the University of Leicester in
Britain Dr Catherine Wade and her
colleagues have analyzed children's
views on surrogacy laws they gathered
quantitative and qualitative information
by talking to children born through
surrogacy
we wanted to stop this process of always
making assumptions about how children
might feel and actually ask them how
they do feel
this is a simulation of the team's focus
group research
should children born through surrogacy
be told that they were born this way I
put yes you can discover a new part
about yourself
it's good to know early because if you
find out you could get a bit angry at
your parents for not telling you you'd
be wondering why you weren't told and
wondering if there was something wrong
with it
in many countries including Britain you
can usually only find out the identities
of your egg and sperm donors but not in
most cases your surrogate
should children born through surrogacy
know who their surrogate was yes because
you could be related to them there's no
reason to not know it's just creating
Mysteries is just creating a problem we
have authority in our lives and it's
nice to have them around it's like a
little bit of like extended family
although circumstances are different for
individuals this information can help
each to develop what is termed their
narrative identity
people are forming integrated life
stories throughout their life it means
that you should try to disclose this
information to Children throughout their
childhood
Catherine and her team's research has
fed into forthcoming reforms to laws in
Britain
this will include a mandatory register
where from the age of 16 you can trace
nearly everything about your genetic
Origins from your surrogate to overseas
donors
some states in Australia have a similar
law
that is the gold standard when children
can learn their genetic origin stories
what's in the best interest of the child
is a good starting point for thinking
about how to better police the global
surrogacy industry
with demand Rising rapidly getting
surrogacy right matters more than ever
we're not going to be able to stop
surrogacy so let's instead regulate it
so that it is a world-class system that
respects the rights of all parties who
are involved
foreign
[Music]
Ridge a correspondent on The Economist
Britain desk
if you'd like to read more about
surrogacy please click on the link and
if you'd like to watch more of our now
and next series please click on the
other link thanks for watching and
please don't forget to subscribe